okay so let's start right there with cbs
news medical contributor dr david agus
uh who's been on the front lines
of this fight dr always good to see you
tom said
there has been so much talk this week
about double masking we saw a bunch of
it at the inauguration or more
it said is it worth putting on more than
one mask
this virus is more infectious which
means fewer particles can spread the
virus
so you need a multiple ply mask the
hospital masks have multiple plies in
them
the cloths mass don't so wearing two
masks gives you multiple ply
we have to do whatever we can to stop
the spread of the virus and we are still
not living by that mass mandate
unfortunately and we're seeing record
numbers
across the country some states have
leveled off but with this new really
infectious variant i am really worried
that it's going to continue to go up
and doctor real quick i know there's
also been a lot of talk over the months
about uh face shields or goggles or do
you recommend those at this point
no i mean you know a face shield
basically tells everyone around you hey
i'm taking this virus seriously but
wearing a face shield in addition to a
mask
doesn't add that much protection unless
there's flying liquid so we wear them
in an emergency room because there's
potential for liquid to be
sprayed but in most places it doesn't
add a lot of value some 20 states now
are saying that they have variant
strains
that have affected people in their state
so what do we know about these
and just how much harder are they
hitting us well
we're not doing a great job first of all
looking for the variant i bet you it's
in most states at the present time
and it's more common than we think and
so if it took
10 minutes of me talking to you to give
enough particles for you to catch cover
19
now that number is four or five minutes
so it is easier to spread
and so we have to be up in our guard
here and you know
what we think now is that the outcome
people get just as sick with this
variant but it's easier to spread
what we think is that the vaccines work
against some of the variants but some of
the variants particularly the brazil and
the south african
there's some question if the vaccines
are as effective as they are
against the uh regular strain of coven
19.
vaccines can only be effective if
they're given
right now the cdc shows that some 39
million doses have been distributed
only 20 million have been administered
how do we jive these numbers
yeah i mean to me it's a crime the
notion that a vaccine sits in a freezer
instead of somebody's arm
today just makes no sense well right now
every state is in charge of their own
distribution plan
and many are not doing a great job and
so we have to get better at as a country
and so many of these things
i think the biden administration is
talking about federalizing that is
taking the role
of what the states are doing and
bringing that to the federal government
and making it more uniform across the
country
so the same criteria of who gets
vaccinated every state and developing
pre-registration software so people can
register and then
distribute the vaccine in a much more
efficient fashion
we have to do better we have heard some
people concerned with the supply and
where will it be
astrazeneca johnson and johnson both
working on theirs right now do we have
any sense of a timeline
when those may be available and what
that does for overall vaccinations as we
go forward
well prior to the new administration it
looked like the johnson johnson vaccine
will be available in mid-february
and astrazeneca beginning of march my
hope is
that those are accelerated there are
tens of millions of those vaccines
sitting in freezer between now and then
the data aren't going to get better the
vaccines aren't going to get better just
the regulators are going to be more
comfortable
they're approved in other countries you
know one of them and so clearly
we need to get them out the more we get
it out now the less the variants are
going to be a problem the more the virus
doesn't have a chance to change
and most importantly we're going to save
lives dr david agus thank you
as always